in the new movie the batman bruce wayne
quickly meets and partners up with
selena kyle also known to dc fans as
catwoman the two have an intensely
intertwined story with bruce helping
selena uncover the fate of her roommate
and the truth about her father carmine
falcone
but there's one other important figure
in selena's life who plays a key role in
the film's story and she never even
shows up on screen this is her mother
maria kyle selena explains her backstory
to bruce one night telling him about how
her mother worked at the iceberg lounge
and met falcone there of course then
this romance led to her and she spends
most of her early childhood years just
hanging out at the establishment as she
talks about her history it becomes clear
that a lot of what she does is based
around his past experience while she
might claim to want to get away from
gotham selena can't seem to leave her
connection to falcone and what happened
to her mother behind it's obvious that
selena loves her mother very dearly
leading her to take her father's
abandonment more personally then when
her roommate ends up dead in a similar
fashion as her mother selena's drive for
answers grows even stronger but casual
fans of the dc eu tuning in to watch the
batman might not know a lot about
selena's backstory and there's a lot
about her mother maria that the movie
doesn't go into in the batman viewers
only really know anything about maria
based on what selena describes to bruce
or falcone but with all the information
the movie provides it appears that this
version of maria is a loving mother who
is just unlucky in life maria works at
the iceberg lounge both before and after
giving birth to selena but unfortunately
she is murdered when selena is very
young and for a long time selena doesn't
know who is responsible without a real
direction in life selena grows up and
develops the thieving skills she
exhibits in the movie intending to steal
some cash leave gotham and start over
aside from her career and relationship
with falcone the batman doesn't reveal
too much else about selena's mother
but one thing is crystal clear and
that's the fact that selena clearly
loves her mother very much and holds no
resentment or bad feelings over how she
grows up instead all of her grief hate
and loneliness is targeted at falcone
who she knows is her father but who had
zero involvement in her life leaving her
to grow up all alone after maria's death
in the comics selena's relationship with
her mother is a little more complicated
and if you can't believe it a little
more traumatic too as revealed in the
solo series catwoman volume 2 which ran
from 1993 to 2001 when selena was a
child her mother maria was in an abusive
marriage with selena's father brian kyle
at one point brian says that maria's
family are refugees possibly from cuba
and she likely speaks both english and
spanish something brian berrata for
along with that maria suffers from
mental illness and faces money pressures
to support the family which includes a
younger sister selena doesn't have in
the film named maggie kyle unfortunately
maria dies by suicide when selena is
very young and she is the one to
discover her in the aftermath of her
mother's death selena's father turns to
drinking and she is eventually separated
from her sister leading to her growing
up on the street and taking up thievery
luckily selena holds on to one
connection to her mother in the form of
gymnastics which her mother enrolls her
in before her death selena exhibits a
natural skill for gymnastics and it
clearly helps her later on when she
becomes catwoman in the comics there's
also a rumor that carmine falcone and
his wife louisa falcone are selena's
real parents though it's never confirmed
and of course a film makes it clear that
falcone is at least her father relating
to that the comics don't show if or how
maria and falcone could have crossed
paths although their connection is a
major focus of selena's story in the
batman if you or anyone you know is
having suicidal thoughts please call or
chat online with the national suicide
prevention lifeline at 1-800-273-talk
8255 or text home to the crisis text
line 741 741